we can see more than 10. from maybe 20 I
don't know how many
corpse lying down on the grounds
two or three meters apart
and the dead bullet
went in from here
and come out from here so this part is
blowing away
and it's just corpse
was wearing this prison uniform
[Music]
thank you
1995
that was a summer day
who is going to do what surgery was
managed by our chief surgeon
and I have I have two Chief certain
so
and that Tuesday afternoon
and one of them they called me into his
office
and he said
I know you are free tomorrow
because I was the only one who
didn't have scheduled surgery
and he said and ask for True nurses
and then
ask for
go to that understand their Department
and ask for assistance
and waiting for me next morning 9 30 at
a
Hospital gate then
next 9 30
they appeared in the car
and shouting at her said follow us and
we said yes follow you
so we jumped into one we start to fall
on them
I asked this driver
where are we going
because I have never been to that part
of the world
and he said this is the way go to the
Western mounting execution ground
oh my God I was so scared it's really
freaked out
what are we doing in the execution
grounds
by that time
the tension between this minority and
Han Chinese and there is government is
can be seen in the society
so somehow I thought I was going to
shoot me
because I'm a minority
by the time we arrived
there's a hill
Western Mountain District as the name
suggests it is inside the mountains
everywhere it's mountains Hills
our true Chief surgeon was waiting for
us and
we arrived and he said you'll wait here
and come around when you hear gun shots
and they said okay at least they are not
going to shoot me because I'm going to
wait here
well since we are all young
inexperienced in such situation
especially just to nurses just scared
what what's going to happen why we're
here
then we started hearing that noise from
the behind the hill
and truck noise engine noise
people's noise and somebody is shouting
and the people chanting
and the whistle is blowing
then we had gun shots
The Gunshot is not like a machine gun
shooting it's like many rifles shoot at
same time
so
we went in
on the left side
at the slope of the mountains
we can see more than 10. from maybe 20 I
don't know how many
uh
corpse lying down on the ground
two or three meters apart
everyone was shaved like me
and the dead bullet
went in from here
and come out from here so this part is
blowing away
and it's just curves
was wearing this prison uniform
you know in China all medical students
during schooling at University they have
seen a lot of crops not like the West
they don't use real crops we use we've
seen lots lots of
dead bodies and dismantled
body parts
so we are not scared
when when we see that
then there was a police officer
shouting at us said go to the far right
the last one is yours
then our third shift surgeon was
standing there
and there was a
body lying down there
whereas civilians uniform
with long hair
it was a man
and the chief surgeon called them and
said you come here
and then told others to put this body
into the one
and he told me no
this is what you are going to do to as
quick as possible
remove liver and the kidney
I actually felt so much relieved
and that is if that is the things
they're asking me to do that is nothing
I can do it straight away no problem
and my old sphere Panic has gone
because I'm they're going to shoot me
from that moment
my body
actually turned into
like Robert
like
trained or programmed the robot
to carry out that following the program
so by the time I got into the one they
have prepared the body already
so I took the scalp and then my chips
surgeon standing next to me on my left
and my rightism and one of my nurse and
the truth and assistant standing
opposite me
so I started cutting straight away
when my scalp
cut his
you know just from here
and the the body tried to you know
struggle in doing this but he was
shot to the right chest
and if he was too weak to resist my
insertion
my chief surgeon said quick be quick
hurry up
so I start cutting it then I saw blood
it was bleeding
and I said this man is alive
because the heart was still pumping the
blood
anyway
since I was told
what to do my only choice is to follow
I took the liver out
both kidney out
and the chief surgeon puts them in a box
and said
now you take your team back to hospital
remember today nothing happened today
right
I lived in a Chinese Communist this
society and I know
what does that mean that means if you
say anything you are in trouble and that
is big trouble
so from that day on none of us has ever
talked about it
was organ harvesting legal in China yes
it's not only legal it is encouraged
as Chinese government says that that
just come from voluntarily donation
that's the LIE
and the Chinese government also says
it's come from executed and prisoner
well
Chinese government the
published that a number of executed
execution it's around 10 000.
but the transplantation organs it is
much higher than UK for example
register the donor is 24 million
against the UK population is one third
or one-fourth
based on such large size of the donation
people size
in UK you need to wait for two years for
one pair of lungs in China they can get
pair of lands in 15 days
it was kicked out
kick-started by my trip surgeon's a joke
she was saying and telling me that
said look at our department we only have
40 beds and 10 of them occupied by your
people it means minorities
and it's addressed 30 occupied by the
Han Chinese among just 160 thousand
there are only five thousand zero
minorities
so now try to calculate five thousand
they got occupied 10 beds
and
155 000 occupied 30 bets
so that tells you this in the amount
minority there are too many cancer
patients among so large purple and
population size Han Chinese they only
need a few bands
so I spent two years and I looked
through
around two thousand cases
and
than I got a result is that
the cancers on the top of the list was
leukemia and Lance cancer
and the thyroid cancer and the malignant
lymphoma
then I come I went back to the medical
textbook and tried to see what is in
common
and I found that thing
those four type of concept if it's in it
is in race
raising in a certain place
then you should immediately looking for
radiation
and we all know and that um
our great country is testing a tone bomb
to against American employees
so we all know that
so as they are testing an atom bomb in
xinjiang
so
that's how I made a connection to the
cancer patient with radiation
there are three large size that you're
in your mind
also located in xinjiang
one of them
was also contributed to former Soviet
unions and nuclear tests program in 1940
and that uranium also is engineer
so from that I
I understood that
people in xinjiang has been
victim of
nuclear test
and they don't hide and they are doing a
nuclear test because every single
nuclear test
you will see it is reported on the
newspaper I said I have a great country
we have successfully conducted another
nuclear test
there's a documentary film made by the
Chinese government
in that film this shows you that
the nuclear test doesn't harm the
animals the crops
and I said if it doesn't harm the
animals why do you test it it means you
don't harm the human being so why do you
need it
you'll test the nuclear bomb is is to
kill
what did you feel like when you realize
the scale of the cancer problem in
xinjiang
Feeling Just hopeless
I don't have a feeling this I don't have
strengths
don't have power to help those people
in xinjiang and one session of
chemotherapy
it costs
um
around one thousand dollars
which is 8 000 yen in Chinese currency
the problem with just people in xinjiang
peasants farmers
it's a yearly income is barely
10 000 yen
they just can't afford that
went to have been diagnosed with that
cancer they just go home
because they can't afford it
so what did you decide to do about all
of that
um
I told you already that I have
investigated 2000s cases and I got
a result that the constipation was a
result of the nuclear test radiation
and then in 2000 uh no it's 1996
um
there was a promotion test examination
I failed in a foreign language
so by that time I'm already fed up with
working with just
um Chinese colleagues with this system
with this Society because there are so
many things and
happen
so I asked and permission I said
can I have a sabbatical leave
and I'm going to study one foreign
language and come back to take this
examination again
so I got one year leave
so I straight come to
um turkey
and what happened is that we have a
national Center in Istanbul
they are helping this Weaver and just
refugees just diasporas
she contacted me and she said there are
two journalists from London
and do you want to know the health
situation in xinjiang
would you like to be interviewed I said
yes why not
they contact back to London
and they decided to make a film
so they asked me if we want to make a
film would you like to be
our guide I said sure yes
because I had that idea I wanted to tell
this world about that
so five of us we went back to xinjiang
we spent six weeks we filmed just
victims and their children
because their radiation
one says atom bomb exploded and when
you were pregnant
the child was like likely to be born
with deformative
but if you was born already then you are
like likely to develop a concert and
there will be also we chopped down a
tree in the mountain
and we send that piece of tree and wood
through British Embassy to London
and then
to examining it
and we were waiting for the result
because we had done everything
then the result come and said yes you
you got the hard evidence
then we left
the hard evidence is inside that tree
the radiation dosage it's 300 times
higher than the tree in Hiroshima
were you scared to expose all of that
yes
I don't scare the darkness
I can go out at midnight alone
everywhere but now
I'm somehow I'm scared in the darkness
alone
and I think that experience and just in
that half year
has
caused this problem
once you came here what was your life
like in the UK
at the beginning I thought well and I
will be welcomed as a hero because
what's what happened to me or what I
have done
then
at the history airport I claimed Asylum
and then
she sent me to a North London
despite my hard evidence it took two
years for a home office to Grant my
application
and during that two years life was being
really hard and to survive
so I applied as bus driver and I drove
bus for seven years because you don't
ask for you see me
and the people asking
do you think all this you are suffering
is
is deserved or
and
you don't regret and they said well this
is the price you pay if you're standing
up such gigantic country
yes I guess this is what I have to cope
with
do you miss China
I miss China China is a great country
however it is this country just having
its very terrible bad time now
by controlled by the Chinese Communist
Party
it is beautiful country
I started the campaigning this organ
against organ harvesting in 2009 you
know it's more than 10 years
the hard part I see is the people they
refuse to believe it
did you realize the consequences of what
you were doing did you realize that you
will never be able to go back to China I
knew that and when that aircraft was
taken off from rimji airport
I was crying
looking at this ground I said okay
bye-bye that's it
but in my opinion it is a real North
Korea then and they ask us to go down in
a basement in one of these old houses
which were about to collapse I was like
waiting for the the sound of a gun
having to know
loading it and then well lights out